[Musique]
à travers mes séries collet mercredi
jean-luc lemoine décrypte un petit peu
ce qui se passe dans l'émission ils
voient des choses qu'on ne voit pas que
ce soit en coulisses où je savais que ce
soit même pendant l'émission il voit des
trucs que nous nous échapper ces choses
qui nous échappent à ce que c'est le
plus fort c'est le meilleur d'entre nous
j'aime bien ces objets comme alain juppé
tout le monde disait que c'était le
meilleur à l'écran ça lui a réussi
lloris a ensuite une question ah bah oui
saluera bailly maire de bordeaux bonjour
je m'appelle françoise vous venez de
fêter la millième donc je voulais savoir
comment faites vous pour vous renouveler
à chaque fois avec brio et qui a eu
l'idée de la séquence du singe qui lance
son caca
[Applaudissements]
je comprends votre question françoise
mais rassurez-vous aux scieries là
encore mille idées pour éviter la
monotonie pour proposant des images
aussi variés que le singe qui lance son
caca l'iguane qui paie tout la girafe
qui suce qui nous regarde ce qu'il crée
tout le temps comme les jours je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez vous il a
transformé le before en the hole clin
d'oeil à la tf1 le problème c'est qu'au
régis sur un peu emballé et alors que
cyril annoncé un changement pour le
lendemain et ils ont voulu faire tout de
suite pour impressionner le patron je
sais pas si c'est leur inconscient qui a
parlé mais c'était bizarre l'antenne et
nous c'est ce hall
dommage je veux faire un truc maggio ici
tous les jours ses geôles
[Musique]
et chérie je vous le dis on va très loin
frej et vous voilà dans les prochains
jours on va lancer une nouvelle émission
qui va s'appeler sky qu ils n'ont pas
fait pour ça que les evs broadcast est
devenu le trou mais quand michel était
plutôt content d'ailleurs au torse de
syrie nous présentait toujours des
nouveaux personnages comme ici un
chanteur méconnu qui porte le magnifique
prenons de jean-luc vous voyez de quoi
je parle jean-luc mais vous avez un
chanteur que vous aimez beaucoup aux tic
s'affaler jean-luc je me plais pour que
vous compreniez bien la fin de l'extrait
il a pourtant ça que c'est la toute
première émission de catherine laborde
ah je vous évite un chanteur
[Applaudissements]
c'est joli
- 2
c'était pas pendant l'émission ça bah
c'est le principe des quatre tiers
arrière pendant l'émission il faut plus
de monde c'est parce que après jean-luc
l'arrêt à chanter alors je sais pas si
vous voulez écouter et surtout je pense
qu'avec ça on va gagner l'eurovision et
des crises et je me rappelle plus bas
salaires non mais le plus drôle c'est
vous allez voir dans son coin maxime
gagné super premier degré et chante
comme si c'était la vraie chanson
[Applaudissements]
ça m'étonne demain parce que j'étais là
même nom depuis exactement vous avez
l'oreille absolue c'est ça qui est
magique alors rachat était chrétienne
j'ai zoomé sur maxime pour éviter
d'humilier valérie s'est plaint avant
force 12 avec cyril bessy pas de sa
faute
j'ai pas ce qui me passait par la tête à
valérie mais suite à la source on s'est
dit que ça serait bien de faire un check
avec le patron offerte je n'aurais pas
dû
[Applaudissements]
baradez
mais bon le plus beau vendu moi c'est
celui qui a mis benjamin castaldi
isabelle morini bosc
ça fait mon bonheur alors pour le
comprendre il faut savoir que benjamin
une oreillette pendant l'émission
ben au cas où cyril fera un malaise
vagal s'il avait soudainement envie
d'aller soutenir gilles verdez benjamin
une oreillette avec laquelle il converse
pendant la pub
sauf que ça isabelle elle ne savait pas
encore qui c'est passé vers elle
non elle était percé que c'était pour
lui parler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
il faut dire qu'en plus c'est isabelle
et benjamins c'est une belle
complémentarité
une belle rencontre il est content
vazemsky dacia que des l'isabelle savoir
quand il savait lui pose une question
comme ça le soul qui fait sens nantes
pas entendre ça se voit pas du tout les
complices de la semaine
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai tout à côté de moi et c'est très
très long et d'un riser à mr ouai on
reviendra à côté moi si vous vous
dérange plus à l'élysée alors l'émission
se renouvelle aussi avec nos invités
comme ce soir et des voitures des
invités de qualité qui ne vais pas
j'adore kindle qui se souviendra
longtemps la diffusion de son nouveau
clip dans l'émission à la commande
tarbes à tarbes a de quoi c'est quoi
l'histoire des jeux
halte à baver comme ça c'est un délire
sur le dos de n'être pas du tout en tout
cas la fin du magnéto tous les jours
notre public avait envie d'acheter son
single vous allez voir dans la 2 chats
[Applaudissements]
jt je l'attend à la sortie je ne sais
quoi dans la tâche
j'imagine que c'est aussi une histoire
de pieds ça correspondait bien mené mais
pas les animaux n'en dégoûtez pas les
autres c'est quoi ce je ne sais quoi
qu'elle avait l'animal
il est gentil qui ne vient il prend tout
bien mais c'est vrai même qu'en série
d'étapes peu maladroit dans ses
lancements
je ne sais pas ce qu'il voulait dire
cyril mais je suis pas sûr que ça fasse
plaisir à cauet on va laisser partir a
kind et parce que le pot il doit lécher
coïc on en marche très fort mon coco
pour le pauvre où c'est pas fait exprès
c'est drôle où c'est la saloperie le
plus discret je te jure et je sais je
sais pas ce que les gens le pauvre doit
partir c'est qu'au pire que d'aller chez
mais c'est pas le temps où nous avons
des invités ou des experts médias
déclarait alors l'expert médias au
départ dans l'émission c'était comme son
nom l'indiqué un expert médias et
maintenant c'est à la discrétion de
cyril ça c'est pas n'importe qui de
compétent ou pas là c'est un peu comme
si tu étais en avion et que le
commandant de bord te proposait de venir
façon dans le cockpit
on va vous dire la vérité parfois
certains d'entre nous ne connaissent pas
les nouveaux venus
et ça ça énerve mathieu parce que
franchement c'est pas trop ça manque de
respect par rapport aux gens si
exactement voilà c'était à l'autre c'est
ça il a essayé d'expliquer sa démarche
de ses collègues
l'expert du jour ce jour là c'était
maxime gasteuil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
oui
là où je suis
aujourd'hui bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est un ami au 1t l'escroc quel
escroc ce possible alors je sais comme
moi comme mathieu je vais encore
m'attirer les foudres des de leurs
moeurs appuyons dire que si moi aussi je
prenais des protéines au lieu de lire
des livres va peut-être plus très loin
et gris l'abus son statut de connect
alors pour les brosser dans le sens du
poil
j'ai décidé de passer ce soit un
excellent avantage de leur dieu et m
alors les deux en mars on rappelle c'est
les les c'est quoi ce sont les faits
comme un million et plus de fans de son
plus grand fan de moi là pourquoi il ya
plus de femmes que de gens qui te
suivent sur twitter pas du tout où j'en
ai 2 2 millions sur twitter
dominion vrai qu'à 2 millions absolument
vous êtes à deux millions et ouais ça a
dépassé les 2 millions ou presque admis
en 900 quelque chose mais pour l'instant
vous n'êtes pas de libye bah oui mais je
vous le dit apprécier ouais un million
neuf mois je vais je dois faire plaisir
aux de leur marche un million bpj à mai
1880 un million huit cent quatre-vingts
bazin très bien de la fin d'émission
d'un million cinq ne peut pas là à oka
de temps en temps il ya des gens qui
t'aiment vraiment souvent moqué étaient
fausses amitiés mais parfois on reçoit
des invités qui l'aiment vraiment comme
ici et c'était busti mais ça manque
chronique après fait non plus n'ont
vraiment à oui alors tu regarde pas
l'émission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la boucherie qui va venir le voir beauce
qc ca
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut ne pas aimer busti en plus et
j'en suis ils échoué
c'est jeanne amour j'ai pas dis j'aime
pas sellal assez mal traduit je ne peux
n'est ni la chasse est rien même pas qui
c'est et c'est le plus gentil de
l'humour gras mais j'ignorais un petit
peu je me souvenais pas de remercier
juste un mot vous commencez à connaître
beaucoup de people iam à moi aussi vous
commencez à un tout petit peu dans vos
amitiés à vous tromper parfois surgir et
bien fabien d alma je vous adore vous
les connaissiez à fabien vous la
connaissiez une actrice comme one man
one woman show oui et alma s'appelle
comment son one woman show et dave allen
bien qu'on dise femmes en scène seul en
scène
[Applaudissements]
merci c'est pas mal hein pour une fois
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui t'aime il peut
pas le sac et j'ai des extraits aussi
est franchement parfois je sais pas où
les mettre
c'est juste des moments gênants de
l'émission avec très peu de dialogues
mais bon comme ça serait dommage de s'en
priver souffrait régulièrement un petit
top 5 des images bizarre de la semaine
ça s'appelle le top gênante à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le moment les syriens bien sûr
qu'on veut atteindre le top d'arca top
rigolade les laisse bien sûr les images
les plus drôles
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait 13 ans
[Musique]
le jeune actu du jour assez le mokhtar
de la cuvée particules
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas beau
allemand n'avait cherché waimes calmos
en plus haut il assume pas complètement
un bon bien sûr dans ce top j'aurais pu
mettre plus de jean-michel car lui les
moments gênants c'est sa vie ah bah ce
soit en effet directement en direct en
fait tous les soirs et il en avait fait
des beaux le journal nous avions reçu
gérard jugnot
ah ouais la valaisanne for baby sitting
qui avait été invité à faire faire un
saut stocks sont qu'est ce qu'un faux
pas le jamais le faire c'est parce que
michel avec toute amitié qui les
communes et chauve c'est gérard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère j'espère pour françois qui est
excellent vraiment dans le film ma mère
formidable et merci d'être là vraiment
françoise et j'aime bien ça patine on
aime bien
j'aimerais
c'est l'autre gars là c'est le chiffre 2
secondes mais prévenez aussi deux avis
je crée donc un phénomène
moi je suis père schéma alors toi tu es
loin ça va j'ai beaucoup fabienne ouais
ouais quoi on a eu un petit truc hop un
petit truc dans les regards loin des
regards parce que vous pensez que vous
non je la regardais en tout cas madame
opposera fabienne vous pouvez être son
style soit dès qu'un truc qu'on soit si
elle courage de l'avouer où je pense
fabienne on va attendre la fin d'année
commenté dire quoi maintenant mais a dit
que tu m'avais dit non c'est pas votre
délire mais je ne suis pas là dedans
mais dans quoi
oui autrement autrement si vous n'aviez
célibataire mais non mais je veux pas
mais n'ont jamais désespéré
j'aime beaucoup cette personne mais je
connais pas vous avez la possibilité de
le dézinguer comment mais jean-michel
non mais
elle en parlera après c'est très gênant
la barre c'était là c'est que j'ai vu
obligé dans ce coin semaine prochaine
alors il faut l'avouer depuis quelques
temps avec jean-michel on a franchi un
palier et pour expliquer ça mathieu est
une belle théorie
[Musique]
c'est dans l'air
oui je connais ça j'aime pas ça je
reconnais et je me souviens aussi il ya
cebenna qui m'avait soufflé aussi ça
hein c'est méchant de dire ça et deux
suspects soit un exemple jean michel rey
parce que sa part lancé son cerveau ça
juste enlever les derniers films qui
restait
[Musique]
monsieur m'a dit rien
le meilleur
j'étais sensé de penser
[Rires]
alors ça non ça est ce qu'on est sûr que
ces moyens là vous allez vous d'excusés
auprès de vous dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi égard qui deviendra avec des
larmes et de long mais surtout des gars
mais chez moi puisque j'ai dit
aujourd'hui que non les conneries que
vous n'êtes rien vous vous trouvez de
s'excuser auprès des gars mélo qui me
traitent de grimaud et 8 offensifs ça à
la voir son papa il à saint-mont
vraiment un gros morceau c'est bon de
l'élégance parisienne
les deux alors excusez-moi agathe mais
elle sait que je lai mon nom là dans son
ensemble mais chez me busch inbev qu'est
ce que j'ai dit aux flottes quand
antoine même excuse moi est-ce que vous
resterez mais sur les gamelles tu es
très belle tu viens très très bien et
vous avons fait le mieux agathe je
m'excuse voilà ce qui n'est pas rien je
te prie de m'excuser non mais c'est un
manque de respect je vous dis voilà
c'est ça barde aurait dû parler de
satoshi kon gupta l'heure
[Applaudissements]
vous sortez un sourire
véritable scandale il ya dix extraits au
pas de charge
c'est lamentable
[Applaudissements]
russian fait miaou miaou après tout
chevauchement
[Rires]
et
ce congrès
[Applaudissements]
oh la la non mais j'attends pour le
respect allez moi aujourd'hui vous en a
marqué que trois extraits agathe et des
déguisés en fée clochette
c'est très difficile de rester sexy dans
cette émission on voit ceux souffrant il
ya quelques semaines j'avais montré
l'image de benjamin parlant d'agathe il
faut resituer à l'époque dentelle noire
mais depuis elle est devenue une
chroniqueuse comme une autre résultat
[Applaudissements]
je trouve
ces battues et ses chants tirés elle pue
le curé n'a pas sorti grand sélection
française monsieur ça fait magnifique
transition pour passer à tout ce que
valent pas voulu voir l'addition si
encore peu de choses et on commence par
le débrief du documentaire sur disney
alors co produit par mathieu et cyril et
je vais vous révéler un petit secret
mathieu était un peu chagrin car il
s'était pas senti soutenu par cyril qui
s'était pourtant beaucoup investi dans
la fabrication d'un programme alors
mathieu a tenu à lui parler de ses
autres produits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non on serait ce que parce je suis
dit ce n'est aujourd'hui a dit steve je
vais disney monsieur disney aujourd'hui
il va craquer ce genre de séquences
style de vie qui m'ont aidé haïti
ça dépend des fois je partage ma mozza
des fois la tomate des parias du tout
non je ne jouais pas
la chine va bien bien sûr il pleut il
mouille c'est à fait à la merci on
embrasse toutes les grenouilles qui
n'ont même genre d'idée une fois y ait
deux filles qui voient passer une fin
aux cards jean michel mr dégueulasse
sa copie en fait j'ai enlevé mon gras
mistral costumés et vous qui m'a demandé
de mettre un certain temps vestiaire les
gars tout moment quel mauvais j'ai vu ça
il y avait des manques je n'avais pas de
manque vous avez déboires à merci il se
trouve donc à créer une cantine qui va
rester c'est ça des gens le font souvent
et le cadeau il est là c'est à marier
il faut apprendre à observer les
moindres détails dans la savane
même les plus étonnants deux formes de
celle là elle vient du bus nous et plus
fils
la famille dans une compétition
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]